hello and welcome to google cloud next
in this session we'll walk through how
to accelerate your move to the cloud
with managed databases
if you're here to learn about cloud sql
bare metal solution for oracle
database migration service and more then
you are in the right place
we'll also explore why google cloud for
your databases
my name is anita kibanguchi grant and i
am the product marketing lead here for
the databases organization
and i have the pleasure of being joined
by gigi goindy group product manager for
databases
so let's go ahead and get started
here's a quick agenda for this session
we'll start with what we're seeing in
the industry across trends
go through five reasons why google cloud
for your databases
will hear from gigi about real-world
customer use cases
and finally end with how to get started
including some important resources you
should check out
so some migration trends
manage services just make sense for
databases
i have never met someone who loved
managing database infrastructure at
least just not yet
when you think about all the care and
feeding necessary to keep your databases
healthy there are a lot of things to
consider
all the work to provision set up and
maintain your hardware
the operating system and database
software
plus all the management tools and going
patches for security and maintenance
scaling the system ensuring that your
backups and restores are meeting
recovery goals
and that the application can continue to
run during
various failure recoveries and scenarios
on top of all this
monitoring all of these things to make
sure that your system is running the way
your business needs to
this is a lot of work
and pretty diverse set of skills that
are needed
consider the thousands of databases run
by many companies this work really adds
up
most importantly these are things that
are just table stakes for you
and typically not the things that help
you out maneuver your competitors
is therefore no surprise that databases
are moving fast to the cloud
according to gartner
75 of all databases will be deployed or
migrated to a cloud platform by 2022 and
this is massive
it's important to note that the cloud
dbms market is not new but what is new
is a growth in cloud revenue
which is actually projected to account
for 50
of the total dbms market revenue by 2023
this trend actually helps reinforce the
notion that cloud service provider
infrastructure and the services that run
on top of them are becoming the new data
management platforms
and because of this it's no wonder that
so many companies are turning to managed
services in the cloud
for their databases that is
so why not let someone else who does it
for millions of deployments and who's
been automating systems like this for
decades handle this for you
let's talk about why google cloud offers
the best place to migrate your databases
we'll start with reason number one
we offer a comprehensive platform that
allows you to securely unify the data
across your entire organization
this allows you to break down silos
increase agility innovate faster and
support business transformation
we connect the different roles that work
with data and provide them a common
platform to build upon
so no matter where you start
there's always more places to go across
analytics databases ai and machine
learning services
bigquery of fully managed enterprise
data warehouse allows you to run
analytics at scale up to 34 lower tco
than other cloud data warehouse
alternatives
spanner provides unlimited scale global
consistency across regions and high
availability up to five nines
looker provides a single shared place
for people and applications to interact
with it no matter the cloud environment
and these are just a few of the key
services you can take advantage of on
the google cloud data
platform as i mentioned earlier
no matter where you start there's always
more places to go with best in class
products across the entire data life
cycle
let's take a look at reason number two
at google cloud we understand that most
companies have a multi-database strategy
in some cases it's intentional
in others it's a natural outcome of
growth and change over the years
plus the fact that re-platforming a
database can be very intimidating
so we've been steadily focused on
building options that help meet you
where you are
today and also give you a path for the
future
when you look at some of the most
popular databases there are great
options on google cloud
these are for oracle sql server postgres
and mysql
and for postgres mysql and sql server
the database migration service provides
a serverless experience for quickly and
safely migrating your databases from
anywhere to cloud sql
we also support non-relational database
workloads
if you're using redis you can now take
advantage of google cloud memory store
for redis
or redis labs one of our key database
partners
from memcached you can now use memory
store for memcached
for hbase
and if you're ready to move off your
hadoop stack you can easily migrate to
bigtable
which has been in production for over 15
years at google and is the original
inspiration for hbase
for all that mongodb you're self
managing you can use mongodb atwas on
google cloud
all of these provide options and
flexibility to quickly and safely
migrate to the cloud helping meet you
where you are
let's take a look at reason number three
we've talked about some of the product
capabilities let's do a deeper dive into
some of them
let's start with cloud sql
cloud sql is our fully managed
relational database service and one of
google cloud's fastest growing top
services
over the past year the team has been
focused on addressing many of the major
blockers for customers and we now have
unique capabilities in the market
we added the database migration service
to migrate your mysql postgres and sql
server workloads to cloud sql
we've
significantly reduced maintenance
maintenance windows by over 80 percent
and we've also launched cloud sql
insights which bring database
observability to your developers
we refer to market to support the latest
versions including postgres 13
because we want to make sure this is the
simplest migration experience for you
cloud sql also offers integration with
kubernetes which makes connecting the
applications easy and secure
it also supports federation with
bigquery and we've seen users carrying
over 125 petabytes of data in cloud sql
on average in one month
and so cloud sql is pretty ready for
your critical relational workloads on
mysql postgres and sql server
the next service we'll do a deeper dive
on is the bare metal solution for oracle
we've taken an optimized approach with
our bms solution for oracle
we provide certified and optimized
hardware for your oracle workloads
allowing you to run all versions of
oracle database including rack and all
the tools and playbooks you use today
such as data guard and rman
you get to maintain your on-premises
licensing run books dbas and system
integrators
google provides management of the data
center with enterprise-grade security
and reliability
we're available in 13 cloud regions and
we're less than two milliseconds away
from google cloud resources
with bare metal solution for oracle you
have full control over how the data is
managed using optimized and certified
sound storage
and finally we'll take a look at some of
the tools and partners available
as i mentioned earlier we announced
database migration service to migrate
your mysql postgres and sql server
workloads onto cloud sql
and we're seeing a lot of customers
start to use database migration service
to migrate their workloads
we also hear that dms is easy to use and
more than 85 percent of the migrations
using dms are underway in less than one
hour
we also announced data stream earlier
this year a cdc and change data capture
service
that provides access to streaming low
latency data from oracle and mysql
databases
with integrations across bigquery cloud
spanner dataflow and data fusion
we also work with partner solutions like
stream and also offer assessment tools
including starter zone and make visor to
get to get you quickly started on your
migration journey
reason number four for why google cloud
is we provide robust tools and
technology to protect and govern your
data throughout its life cycle
we realize that security and governance
are key concerns for many of our
customers and providing these controls
are key to peace of mind for your
databases
we offer built-in data protection at
scale and this is by default all your
data is automatically encrypted while in
transit and at rest
we've also added customer managed
encryption keys for some of our key
services including cloud sql and spanner
secondly we supply tools and technology
to efficiently govern your data
cloud identity and access management
provides access control and visibility
into security policies across your
organization
thirdly we support compliance
requirements with third party audits and
certifications
and finally we believe that trust is
created through transparency and so we
provide tools such as access
transparency which give you visibility
into accesses by either support or
engineering
and all these capabilities ensure that
your data is protected
and finally let's look at reason number
five for why google cloud
it goes without saying that your
databases are as good as your
availability
we offer five nines industry-leading sla
across our cloud native databases
spanner firestore and bigtable
and four nines sla for bigquery
and these databases are actually built
on google's dedicated network and
they're battle tested by google cloud
services used by billions of users
and they're actually made available for
your use
all these services are simply unmatched
for speed scale security and capability
for any sized organization
and these availability slas ensure that
your business continues to run without
disruption
so there you have it
five key reasons why migrating your
databases to google cloud is a good move
for your business
from the fact that we offer managed
services for your oracle mysql postgres
and sql server workloads including redis
mongodb and hbase
to the sophisticated security and
privacy controls
all the way to the five ninths
availability across some of our key
services
i realized that was a ton of information
so it'll be good to be able to bring all
these things to life so let's do a deep
dive into three key customer use cases
um across some of these key services so
i'm excited to welcome gigi group
product manager to talk more to us
welcome gigi
thank you anita indeed that is a great
overview of our portfolio and the
reasons why customers are choosing a
solutions
and 100 agree with you in my 20 years of
my my career here in silicon valley i
have not met a single person who wakes
up in the morning and say
managing databases really excites me
what they do wake up and tell us is how
we can help them run these databases
more efficiently more reliably
help them build new
ex customer experiences at the same time
lowering their cost
one such customer that i like to talk
about is a leading travel
travel service provider or travel
company you might say
this industry is a lot of churn and
customers are trying to be these
companies are trying to build new
experiences for their customers and
their customer base is also evolving
so this company turned to us and the
reason they like they like the strategy
is the breadth of our product portfolio
whether it be the world's leading five
nines uh databases such as spanner or
our ability to provide a
stable secure high performance home for
the legacy databases estates which might
be running on databases like oracle
this particular customer had a lot of
oracle databases running on premises on
aws you name it
with bare metal solution we were able to
provide them a home where they can
migrate as is and then like and then
upgrade these databases
to spanner or other cloud native
databases at their own pace
not only they were able to keep all of
their
run books and playbooks and partners as
is
at the same time they were able to
benefit
from the extreme low latency to google
cloud so that they can iterate their
workloads back and forth between a cloud
native database and a traditional
database
such as oracle
what was a real near needle mover for
them they had plethora of oracle
versions and they probably used every
possible oracle
ha technology with oracle bms they were
able to leverage those technologies as
is
and move their databases to production
in a record amount of time
on the other spectrum of industry i
would like to share an example with a
leading german bank we are working on
you might know
all of you might know banks are really
particular about
data security not that others are not
but they're regulated towards data
security data residency and privacy
with the
oracle bare metal solution they were
able to meet this stringent regulator
require regulatory requirements place to
place upon them as a business
at the same time with the help of our
engineering teams they were able to
migrate over a hundred mission critical
oracle databases
to oracle vr metal solution within three
months
now they're using the data setting in
the databases in bare metal solution to
bring new experiences
by using cloud data databases in gcp
last but not the least i would like to
talk about one of my favorite use cases
is this big ticketing marketplace
which was which built the entire
business on a clustered data on a set of
cluster databases running
on oracle and
they look to dcp to help them
take the smart marketplace and transform
it
in an extensible scale
that spanner provides extensible and
five nine availability that spanner
provides
but this journey is not simple and needs
a lot of steps
and iteration between them
so
they decided to move their cluster
databases which was running on aging
hardware to the state-of-the-art
infrastructure provided oracle benefit
solution that enabled them to not only
modernize or at least lower the cost of
running their databases using modern
hardware on oracle bare metal solution
at the same time start modernizing their
existing applications with google cloud
spanner
not but last but not the least
this customer has been live with running
some one of the largest oracle cluster
in any public cloud of environmental
solution and we are very happy to have
them here
with that being said anita i'll hand it
back to you to take us to this
presentation thank you for your time
thank you so much gigi
those are all such great example use
cases and i'm sure many of them will
actually resonate with you
so how should you think about moving
forward with your migration journey
a good migration plan is going to have
four key phases
first your assessment phase where you
work to understand exactly what you have
already
secondly based on that assessment you
start to plan what you should move and
how you should move it
third you start to execute the migration
itself
and finally you fine tune and optimize
what you've migrated
i think this should sound pretty
familiar gigi just talked about the
customer who actually went through
these type of four key phases and
they're actually still going through
that journey
and i realized that we're representing
this migration plan as a single circle
but in reality it's a bit more recursive
in that you'll have your high level
migration plan
but then you also have groups of
applications called migration waves that
they have that have their own specific
plan as well
and each subsequent plan in theory
is adapting the lessons from previous
migration waves
in addition it's not uncommon to go back
and forth between each of the four
different phases
it's all about building that migration
muscle memory and realizing that this is
a journey
and so what tools do we offer and all of
these should now sound very very
familiar
for your database assessments you should
check out midvisor and stratozone
we have 50 plus regional champions
trained on mcvisor that are a
combination of ce's pso and partner
engineering teams who are ready to help
you carry out your assessments
we also offer partner programs as well
we also talked about the database
migration service for your my sql
postgres and sql server workloads
and finally
we're also working really hard to
improve that customer experience or
crossword teams and services
to help you
quickly and safely and efficiently
migrate your databases to google cloud
and last but not least make sure you
check out this great white paper
resource with a lot of good information
around migrating your databases
it has a lot of the content we spoke
about in this presentation and actually
provides it in much more detail it will
be included in the resource section of
this presentation
you can also get started with some
hands-on labs as well
i know that cloud sql is
widely represented and so you can
actually get started
on checking out the hands-on labs there
and so i'd like to thank you again for
joining us for this presentation and for
this session
and we absolutely value your feedback so
please take the time to provide it let
us know what we did well
and what we could have done to improve
for next time
thank you so much and thanks again gigi
for joining me in this session thanks
for having me